safer sex kids und herzlich willkommen
zu einer neuen folge jump league wir
haben heute wieder eine zu schöne stadt
von text und die hat uns vorgestellt ein
bisschen sportlicher werden hier bei
unseren jump we can das mal wieder denn
ich habe vor ewigkeit man die
liegestütze gemacht und dann nochmal
eine liegestütz change und heute machen
wir die schwindel challenge das heißt
ich laufe für jeden jump fail jeden job
fällt und für jeden kill im deathmatch
dreimal um eine studie die den rollen
die ab da wird mir es wird einem
durchaus schnell schwindelig aber wir
gucken einfach mal wie das jetzt hier
läuft und legen direkt los heißt jeder
jump wird knallhart bestraft und mit
jedem jahr wird das alles zunehmend
schwieriger denn mir wird ja auch
schwindel ich bin ja da drin also
dreimal rumrennt mit dem ordentlichen
tempo
das macht einen jetzt nicht komplett aus
oder so und man merkt schon deutlich ihr
könnt es auch gerne mal zu hause
probieren wenn ihr alleine wohnt sonst
denkt auch familie nämlich dass sie
vollkommen durchgedreht sein immer ohne
scheiß also als wird einem schon so ein
bisschen die sie als man wird sich schon
ein bisschen schreckt wenn man das macht
von einem mal wohlgemerkt macht uns aber
dreimal direkt miteinander wenn man an
einer irgendeiner stelle hängt dann hat
man ein richtiges problem
deswegen versuche ich erstmal so safe
wie möglich die sachen hier zu spielen
um keine unnötigen schwindel punkte zu
sammeln
weil es später sicher noch richtig
abgehen wird bei den hart modulen
warum sind so viele leute der runde ok
kraska egal umso besser für mich so und
zack zack zack leisten schon mal dass
die zutaten für vier pfeile und sind so
weit
ohne job fällen nach drei module das
eigentlich auch module bei dem es sich
um den fällen muss sagt alles klar gold
legkow hier gut und es der erste job
viel okay leute und jetzt drei runden
und zwar so enorme tempo 12
und 3 und dann direkt weiter ohne pause
alter schwierig hat gerade eben schon
einen aufnahmen versucht leute und es
wird nicht besser mit der zeit und
hierneis ok ok dieses modul ist auch
alles andere als klar muss man sagen
hier kann man schon gerne einige fans
sammeln sind hier alles klar und
leggings alles plastik statement ist in
ordnung nichts weltbewegendes nein als
ob als ob es war das 2 3 ok dieses modul
schaffen ist schon ein kleines bisschen
schwindelig aber müssen jetzt irgendwie
hier rauskommen
ok jetzt nicht in dieses loch gefallen
dass mir gefallen hier unten
das war nicht nochmal machen so
schönsten ecken der sprung geht alles
klar
der hier wir können wir den machen
können so machen
ja ja ja wohl aus hierüber ja okay das
waren eigentlich die 2 schwierigeren
hier in den modulen jetzt zack zack ist
schon blutet egal jetzt noch mal zurück
wir haben ja auch wieder den checkpoint
alles da wo du fünf abgeschlossen so
weit muss ja uns zwei mal um die eigene
achse drehen erzählt habe und weil alles
klar der shader com war klar hier sagt
hammerl schon jetzt schön safe weiter
schön safe keinen job viel machen kann
eher sinken es kobold keine simple
machen so ok noch das letzte enorme
modul steht an hier sagt sack sagt der
andere bei 78 wir sind bei 59
wohlgemerkt mit dem schwindel programm
sondern waschgang schwindel programm ab
werk sagt alles klappt es und da
vielleicht einfach auch schnell weiter
springer wolle und hier ist noch eine
kiste nichts interessantes für uns aber
es geht weiter wir sind relativ langsam
unterwegs würde ich sagen so jetzt
müssen wir rein hab hier kommt aber
keine jobs damit das ist immer gut
schön drin im gebäude ohne jobs und
jetzt hier so um die ecke alles klar
und zack zack als ob dieses modul leute
nein mein gott oh mein gott ich bin tot
ich bin als kathode das ist modul das
habe ich noch nie gefunden doch einmal
habe ich schon gefährlich aber ich
schaffe es ungefähr nie nein bloß alles
ok wack my life weiter ja okay jetzt
bloß müssen bloß konzentriert bleiben
wenn wir unkonzentriert werden und dann
mehrere jobs machen nun zu verkaufen
sowie instant dann sagt unser frühstück
wieder hallo das war nicht okay
die kiste können mitnehmen eisenstein
schwert pfeile okay das ist gut so weit
und jetzt wird's tricky dass der
tripartite sprung habe ich auch schon
seit ewigkeiten nicht mehr gemacht hat
kann hier raus da wohl alles klar und
hier ist es jetzt auch gar nicht so easy
nämlich hier ohne sprinten einfach
loslaufen dann hier wieder mitsprinten
und hier so alles klar und jetzt der
sprung geht auch noch hierhin aber das
ist jetzt die schwierigkeit wie schaffen
wir den sprung die leute
ja als hopp morgen was war das ich war
noch so weit entfernt
und 3 hinsetzen weil ich habe eigentlich
das gefühl das ist nicht so super
erbärmlich abgesprungen bin trotzdem
weil ich einfach noch so weit von dem
ziel block entfernt
das war locker noch ein halber block der
gefehlt hatte wtf dahin zu kommen zu
diesem letzten sprung ist schon nicht
super easy auf dem weg dahin kann auf
jeden fall jump welt sammeln hier vor
allen dingen aber wenn man da oben ist
ist es halt noch mal richtig richtig
schwer und jetzt nicht so wirklich ein
paar wichtigen sprung machen soll da
oben ehrlich gesagt das ist das was ich
am wenigsten mag am wenigsten kann
sowieso also bis hier geht eigentlich
alles aber ab hier vollkommen
planlosigkeit wir probiert es nochmals
und ganz raus nein ok alles klar 1 und 3
und weil da geht's ja okay wir müssen
wir müssen wieder aufstehen beim schönen
ford weiter alles klar
und jetzt admins deathmatch wir haben
drei gegner das heißt es können maximal
neun kills in der ganzen runde gemacht
werden ich würde mal vermuten dass wir
nicht alle neuen kids machen aber wir
müssen natürlich aggressiv spielen
okay da sind direkt alle gegner auf
einem haufen wir stürzen uns rein haben
wir reisen aber hier können schon mal
klappen würde ich sagen da bis da die
clean up lage hier der fristen erst mal
alles klar
diese random hitze immer das sechs
blöcke hat einen gekillt und kümmert
sich irgendwo verstecken
ich stelle mich hierhin und jetzt
schnell drei runden
123 die sache ist nämlich auch hier dass
mein platz ziemlich knapp bemessen ist
in meinem zimmer weil man halt einfach
winzig ist weil ich ein bettelarmer
student bin partie und dementsprechend
muss ich halt meine studie durch die
gegend schieben um überhaupt um ihn rum
zu kaufen laut dessen gegner fakt 2
alles klar
ich muss meinen stuhl einfach durch die
gegend schieben leute um überhaupt um
den ruhm kommen zu können so klein ist
mein zimmer hier kommt nein nein nein
nein ok alles gleich wieder ab geschockt
aber abstauben wird nicht bestraft
wenn ich selbst kills mache aber die
sache ist ich muss von spiel okay wenn
jetzt auch einen letzten gegner bist du
klein transfer steht das sind alles
versteht werden auch drei fall die
kommentiert wir können uns auf viele
kräften wenn man hier den coffee table
finden
ich höre ich verstehe die hits von den
leuten die server nicht
es ist so seltsam ich verstehe dich
jetzt nicht alles okay wer mich holt das
gefühl dass es für pc-systeme sich ein
bisschen geändert hat irgendwie das
gefühl die anzeigen sind ganz anders
wenn leute sterben
aber wer misst 1 gekillt und wir müssen
jetzt ganz schnell drei direkt hinter
uns ja da ist nämlich ach du scheiße ok
hat uns mit dem pfeil getroffen
mit dem fall auflauern
wir hoffen jetzt wird wenn wir mit mehr
hits ich verstehe diese was sind das
witz ich komme nicht an den jungen dran
also entweder 30 prozent aller leute auf
dem server hier top kill aura oder
irgendwas irgendwas anderes stimmt nicht
so oder so müssen jetzt damit arbeiten
hier gibt es einfach alles klar wir
geben auf dem fall und habe dann
theoretisch direkter konkurrent wenn wir
direkt in dem stück ist mir jetzt ich
komm ich dann kommt ran ich komme
einfach nicht dran an den typen matisse
aber leute so oder so ich bin jetzt
ausreichend fällig das war es im
heutigen video wenn es euch gefallen hat
würden wir über daumen nach oben folgt
und über weitere weitere zahlreiche
chelsea den in den kommentaren und dann
sehen uns im nächsten video wieder haut
rein macht's gut